derrière les murs du séminaire de saint
sulpice et conserver une importante
partie de la mémoire de montréal
car au fil du temps les sulpiciens ont
accumulé des archives qui remonte au
xviie siècle
à chaque fois je raconte des chercheurs
il nous parle de ses archives le qui
sont à peu près les archives et plus
importante après celle de la compagnie
l'avait du scion au canada au plan
historique en plus de préserver sur la
rue notre dame ouest des registres et
des archives
les anciens seigneurs de l'île de
montréal sauvegarde aussi au grand
séminaire de la rue sherbrooke ouest
des oeuvres d'art des livres rares et
des objets remontant au régime français
le journal le devoir nous apprenait que
le personnel qui veillait à la
conservation de ce patrimoine a été
licencié pour moi c'est le sentiment
d'un immense gâchis puisque ça faisait
des années que des laïcs travaillait au
service des sulpiciens pour la
préservation des collections que ce soit
les les archives mais aussi les biens
mobiliers et toucher des formes
maintenant sont réduits à néant par ce
que l'on choisit de ne plus investir
dans ce patrimoine
face à la polémique et dans l'urgence la
ministre de la culture place des trésors
des sulpiciens sous la loi du patrimoine
culturel
mais lorsque le gouvernement irait mieux
des rides de protéger et des obligations
qui viennent avec ceux pour les
propriétaires de févier obligation de
préserver en bonne état obligations
fille de ne par faire sortir les pieds
du québec pour certains historiens le
patrimoine des sulpiciens est un bien
commun et il ya plusieurs solutions pour
bien le préserver les congrégations
religieuses rechignent parfois à céder
leurs archives pour toutes sortes de
raisons qui sont liés a parfois une
sorte de secret mais il existe depuis
quelques années une fondation du
patrimoine et des archives religieuse
qu'on a créé pour la grande région de
montréal
cette fondation là elle est vraiment
interpellé et c'est peut-être là le lieu
pour discuter d'un atterrissage
nous avons cogner à la porte du
séminaire de saint sulpice puis à la
porte du grand séminaire
nous n'avons pas pu obtenir le point de
vue officiel des suppliciés
cette histoire est loin d'être terminé
puisque au cours des prochains jours la
ministre de la culture va envoyer 1
détention de placement aux gestionnaires
du patrimoine des sulpiciens d'autres
questions demeurent par exemple comores
seront conservés ces archives et où
seront tels localiser ici luis et
déprimait radio canada montréal